this is Steve Balmer the CEO of
Microsoft between 2000 and 2014 which
gave him a net worth of $112 billion
seeing this you'd probably be inclined
to think that Steve was one of the most
respected Tech Executives of all time
but it's actually quite the opposite in
fact aside from actual frauds and
incompetent leaders Steve bomber is
often viewed as the worst big Tech CEO
of all time and many attribute his
insane wealth to nothing more than just
dumb luck why you ask well for starters
Microsoft stock fell 36% under his
leadership which translates to a market
cap loss of roughly hundred billion
itself many would say that this was
because Microsoft screwed up with
smartphones and Windows 8 under his
leadership in fact the stock actually
started rallying when Steve bomber
announced his exit but even more than
stock performance much of the Tech
Community just viewed bomber as a meme
there were all these Infamous clips of
him laughing at the iPhone and going
absolutely crazy on
stage $500 fully subsidized with a plan
I said that is the most expensive phone
in the world and it doesn't appeal to
business customers because it doesn't
have a keyboard which makes it not a
very good developers developers
developers developers developers
developers Developers
yes but if we look past these funny
clips and this goofy personality we'll
see that Steve was much more than just a
tech executive for Steve Microsoft
wasn't just a company that he led it was
a company that he bled he was fiercely
loyal to everything Microsoft as he
truly loved the company I have four
words for you
I
love this company
[Applause]
yes he thought that Microsoft was hands
down the best company in the world and
that everyone should use everything
Microsoft in fact he would eventually go
on to buy the Clippers and he would
force all the players to ditch their
iPads and iPhones you could say that he
was basically the Louis lit of Microsoft
but it wasn't just loyalty that Steve
had going for him fundamentally speaking
he actually did a pretty good job in
fact under his leadership Microsoft's
revenues and profits more than tripled
of course this was never reflected in
the stock price but that's not something
that he had control over so was Steve
bomber actually just an enthusiastic dud
who got lucky beyond belief or was he
just a misunderstood leader who more
than deserved his $12 billion
compensation
Microsoft's $100 billion bet on bomber
is no doubt controversial but another
$100 billion bet that's not
controversial is their investment in
cash equivalence and short-term
Investments or mostly bonds if you're
not familiar with bonds it's a way to
lend money to the top corporations and
governments in the world these
institutions will then turn around and
use their money to fund expansion
efforts launch new prodct prodcts and
grow their profits and in return for
helping them with their expansion these
institutions will pay you back with
interest traditionally Bond investing is
seen as something that conservative old
people do to protect their savings but
thanks to the high interest rate
environment bonds are paying higher
yields than ever in fact one-year bills
from the US government are currently
yielding 52% and 10year notes from the
US government are currently yielding
4.7% if you'd like to take advantage of
these high interest rates and lock in
high yields for yourself please consider
checking out our upcoming Bond investing
app Silo in the description below but
anyway getting back to Steve bomber the
story of Steve bomber actually goes all
the way back to the 1970s to the dorm
rooms of Harvard maybe you've wondered
what it would be like to know someone
like Bill Gates or Steve Jobs before
they were famous in school or college
well luckily for bomber that's exactly
what would happen as he would end up
across the hall from Bill Gates at
Harvard hearing this your probably
thinking oh well Bill and Steve probably
founded Microsoft together that must be
why Steve got so rich but that's not how
things played out you see Steve was from
a relatively conservative immigrant
family who very much valued the
stability of a college degree and a 9
to-5 job so dropping out of Harvard to
bet it all on a software company with
Bill wasn't exactly Steve's cup of tea
so when Bill dropped out Steve would
simply wish him good luck and farewell
and stick with Harvard he would
eventually graduate Magna kumlade with a
degree in Applied Mathematics and
economics in 1977 and he followed this
up with a traditional job as an
assistant product manager at proin
gamble as far as the general public was
concerned Steve had done it he had a
degree from Harvard and a stable job at
a legacy giant but Steve couldn't help
but feel that something was missing
maybe it was the monotony of a 9 to-5 or
the lack of creativity he couldn't tell
but he was determined to find out in
fact he would turn around and try to
break into Hollywood by writing
screenplays in his free time
unfortunately this never went anywhere
and Steve would find himself lost once
again he figured that maybe returning to
school would help him so he would enroll
in a graduate program at Stanford but it
wasn't until Steve got a call from Bill
that he would finally find his path at
the time Microsoft was filled with a
bunch of extremely smart Tech dudes but
what they didn't have was a business
dude and as the company grew larger and
started having more more meetings and
negotiations this became increasingly
apparent Microsoft needed a business
leader so bill would call up his friend
from Harvard Steve Balmer and this time
Steve wasn't hesitant after all he had
nothing to lose he already had a degree
and Real World Experience so if
Microsoft didn't work out he could
always just get another job or return to
Stanford in fact when Steve told his mom
about his plan to join Microsoft she
said quote okay okay we hear you but if
it doesn't work out you'll go back to
Business School
right Steve replied right but he would
never come
back Steve's initial salary was quite
modest $50,000 per year but that wasn't
the entire offer Bill also offered Steve
5 to 10% equity in the company depending
on his performance Steve started off as
basically the scapegoat anything that
the tech guys didn't want to do Steve
would handle this included little things
like cooking and washing bottles to big
things like setting up accounting and HR
but it wasn't until later on in 1980
that Steve would really prove his worth
you see in July of 1980 IBM would
approach Microsoft with a deal to make
software for their new computers
normally this would be great news but
there was one major problem Microsoft
didn't actually have what they were
looking for an operating system and this
is when Microsoft would pull off one of
the biggest Bluffs in Tech History
though Microsoft didn't have their own
OS they did know where to find one a
local computer company called Seattle
computer products had an OS called Kudos
which was very similar to what IBM was
looking for the operating system Tim
Patterson wrote he called it qos the
quick and dirty operating system so
Microsoft's plan was to basically get
IBM to allow Microsoft to go out and buy
qos and modify it for IBM's needs but
there was obviously a flaw with this
plan IBM could easily just go to Seattle
computer products directly so it was up
to Microsoft to convince IBM to let them
be this sort of middleman and that's
where Steve bomber comes into play Steve
would basically become Microsoft's sales
guy with IBM and let me just say Steve
would hit it out of the park as this
deal would basically make Microsoft IBM
didn't even know what was happening in
fact they thought that they had pulled a
quick one over on Steve and these
college dropouts you see Microsoft
didn't ask for as much money upfront or
a per copy royalty like IBM was
expecting them to so from their
perspective they thought they had a slam
dunk deal they didn't have to pay as
much and Microsoft was going to handle
all of the groundwork in customizing qos
for IBM and in return all Microsoft
wanted was the ability to sell this OS
to other companies that's it without
giving it a second thought IBM would
agree to pay Microsoft $45,000 for what
would end up becoming MS DOS on the
Surface Microsoft didn't make a good
deal as it would cost them $50 to
$75,000 just to acquire qos but Bill
Gates very much knew what they had just
pulled off they had basically gotten IBM
to largely pay for a new OS that
Microsoft would own and IBM would
popularize despite not even creating the
software in the first place it wasn't
until decades later that the general
public really began to understand what
was really at stake for Microsoft with
this deal but Bill he knew immediately
and as promised in 1981 he would hand
over an 8% stake to the man who made it
possible Steve Balmer over the next few
years Microsoft would follow through
with their deal with IBM and deliver to
them a customized version of qos called
msos msos would end up being a solid
success and lead to a very successful
IPO but the real magic didn't happen
until
1985 in 1985 Microsoft would take Ms
Doos add in a graphical user interface
and call it windows and this would take
msos from being a successful product to
being a legendary
product the rest of the 80s and 90s were
pretty smooth sailing for Steve as
Microsoft grew so did his title and
wealth he went from being a manager to
being an executive leading various
divisions across Microsoft including
operations sales OS development and
support and all of this climaxed when
Bill Gates decideed to step aside at the
turn of the century making Steve balber
the new CE of
Microsoft this brings us back to the
question of the day did Steve bomber
deserve to earn $112
billion well that's hard to say frankly
because it's hard to say that anyone
truly deserves that sum of money but we
can look at it through a different lens
instead of looking at it from an output
perspective we can look at it from an
input perspective did Steve bomber make
an 8% contribution to Microsoft back in
1980 well the answer is absolutely he's
spearheaded the deal that not only put
Microsoft on the map but literally led
to the creation of their hero product
windows so no Steve did not just get
lucky the only reason people even say
that is because Steve didn't immediately
take the plunge with Bill Gates and Paul
Allen in 1975 so history has basically
painted Steve as this guy who just
happened to come in as Microsoft's 38
employee and got an 8% stake just
because he was friends with Bill Gates
and his goofy bubbly personality simply
plays into this persona but this really
isn't a fair assessment while Steve
wasn't there from day one he very much
played a role of being a co-founder or
at least the role of being their first
business executive and the IBM deal was
simply his biggest contribution let's
not forget that Steve also spent 34
years as a Microsoft executive 14 of
which were spent as CEO
also during his stint as CEO Microsoft
came out with some of their most iconic
products including the Xbox Windows XP
Windows 7 and even Azure which is often
quoted as being what saved Microsoft not
to mention Steve tripled Microsoft's
revenue and profit so Microsoft stock
not going anywhere had more to do with
the Doom crash and the 2008 crash than
it did with anything that Steve did or
didn't do and it was eventually the
shareholders that pushed him out but he
still very much loyal to Microsoft to
this day in fact he's by far Microsoft's
largest individual stakeholder retaining
over half of his original stake at
4.5% for perspective that's five times
more than even Bill Gates who only owns
0.9% of Microsoft today so not only did
Steve bomber play a crucial role in the
early days of Microsoft but there's no
question that Steve is by far
Microsoft's most loyal executive I mean
he probably wouldn't have left if it
wasn't for show holders pushing him out
so does Steve bomber deserve $112
billion well I can't answer that
question but what I can say is that
Steve bomber didn't just get lucky he
deserves his money just as much as any
of his Cent billionaire peers and that's
why Microsoft paid him $112
billion if you'd like to take advantage
of high interest rates and have the
government and the top companies pay you
47% check out our bond investing app
Silo in the description below but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next
one